we met knoxville on a television
commercial audition
well there's a lot of different versions
of how we met well let me tell you my
version
because
okay you tell me your version then i'll
tell you the version we man told the new
york times
i'm gonna i'm trying to curb my uh my
propensity for telling people their own
stories and my version of it
real quick tell me your version i mean i
just know that that uh he met on an
audition for a commercial and and he had
the idea to try to eat 50 eggs and he
said oh hey man i'm doing this thing i
think you'd be great for it
his uh
ex-wife owned a clothing company and i
had met her through another friend and
she had me haul uh
clothing supplies you know yards of uh
what do you call that
style yeah textile stuff around where
they were sewing and everything and we
had big loads she would uh big loads
that's funny she would uh have knoxville
come with me and we just started
business stuff you know he started
telling me about this show and
everything and i told him the show
sounds horrible and stupid and violent i
said you and i should do like a you know
lino you know mcmahon thing right there
you know let's do it he goes let's he
goes let's try this then if this doesn't
work we'll try something else you know
and so he had me write him ideas and i
wrote him like 10 ideas and he said
you're going to do all these ideas so
the
the joke about how a jackass was written
by preston lacy was founded in truth
not really i was when i was a writer in
the beginning yeah
where did that come from like somebody
said oh who comes up with the ideas and
the answer was president lacy right i
was on imdb back when imdb was just
beginning out and starting who uh was
that quote from
was it we man said president kristen
chris pious did yeah preston lacy right
and then that just everybody started
saying in all the interviews
it's so good but i tell you that has not
opened any doors across the world that
in a bus pass i'll get you on the bus
[ __ ]
what what were some of those original
ideas that you wrote gosh
i would have to meet chase and we man
for sure that's one of my favorite um
bits
oh the pp guy where i peed myself right
right yeah that one she's so hard to
remember now it's been so jeff said i
love your idea but you've got to
convince we man to do it and he's kind
of hard to convince the stuff i didn't
know him so i had to tell we men first
day i met him that's why we're gonna do
again our underpants and go through west
hollywood chasing each other around and
he was like
that might be funny okay
wow
that's so funny i wonder if if jeff
tremaine pitched it to him if if he
would have been
oh like would have been less receptive
if it came from someone else
right maybe when you said you were
hauling stuff that's because you're
driving a truck
a pickup truck then just yeah i just i
swear i did for extra money when i first
moved to california is i hauled
furniture and you just do odd jobs and
stuff and i pick up trucks so you didn't
meet noxa on a audio no i met him
through uh uh beautiful jason the guy
who uh shot him with a taser yeah yeah
that's what i i meant all right yeah but
then also i said so many stupid things
in interviews and they caught on i said
that i went to open audition with 500
people and i ate a whole bunch of
bananas with the peels on and that's
when they hired me on the spot when you
went to an open audition for jackets
with 500 different contestants and
that's what i had heard it was like an
open casting call
[Music]
that was that's my version
of massachusetts
yeah it's like all right now break your
finger yeah
right
wow
so you died it was a horrible terrible
idea
but that's just knoxville describing it
you hadn't seen like the no that was
before i hadn't seen any video at all
you know and then he asked me right
around that same time he wanted me to
run and run drive over him with my truck
you know run run him over wow and i
wouldn't do it but the only reason i
would do this because i didn't have
another truck and he didn't have the
money to replace my truck you know and i
used it to make a living do you know
just barely could barely make a living
as well as 1998 i lived in los angeles
and i made 12 thousand dollars
12 thousand dollars and that was from
driving the pickup yeah and it's like
how did you even make it you know what i
mean sir there's no truth to the
audition story did you ever like uh
audition for commercials or
no it's just never been in a commercial
with giant oxford my version's wrong
you've never been in any commercials and
i've been in a bunch of commercials just
none with him
okay then with john knoxville so you
were like yeah you're like becoming an
actor yeah yeah i want to be actor i was
on the tonight show with jay leno um for
almost two years doing the skits they do
at the beginning of the show yeah i did
a lot of skits on there nice that's a
legit gig
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
yeah
uh